[Musique]
pour ceux qui ont vu le film big avec
tom hanks et mais dans tel outil mais un
dollar étude son avenir squeeze va
bientôt tous dépassés en abonnés on
teste le skate électrique
mike s'y colle est ce que tu es prêt
mike c'est parti
[Musique]
alors aujourd'hui je pars la rencontre
de youtube deux américaines nous appelle
les listings nollet les anglais georges
pernoud live view et mike prew htc qui
j'ai écouté j'ai trouvé un peu bizarre
et on les angles plus près dans le
paquet et le sens des contres que cette
simplement des cookies pour chiens
[ __ ] ils sont fous ces ricains [ __ ]
les étoiles à tokyo
jennifer aniston michael jackson
brad pitt cep la frite l'estate c'est
vraiment n'importe quoi je tiens une
sorte de pharmacie parce que j'ai des
maux de gorge
il propose pour les maux de gorge des
fisherman's friends soute de ma gueule
parce que les tictacs aussi talent mais
qui fait un peu chaud la voulait pas
mettre la clé m'a raté ça mais qui fait
un faux choix la plupart être la clim ok
j'aime mieux ça alors décapotable truc
le plus titré du monde juste ci a mis un
petit achat on se prend plein la gueule
quoi ces problèmes de riches ont pas
sentir alors shiro le food market
ils vendent un nombre incroyable de
graines ce qui est assez pratique quand
tu es un oiseau
je sais pas qui
ce type de doubler
mais c'est génial un tournant on est sur
une aire d'autoroute américaine et j'en
profite pour montrer notre véhicule de
location surestime d'autres non les
boues véhicule familial de papa et maman
qui est chaud pour faire ça moi non vous
et qui veulent tout faire pour que tu
décides c'est parti pour la traction men
in black tuer les aliens en plastique
elle girl
il aurait pu rajouter un n là quand même
j'étais à deux doigts de pouvoir
l'acheter la la sucette avenger captain
america s'est revendu sept normales
on a juste sous un papier reçue mon
objectif est clairement de prendre des
photos de bob l'eponge c'est mon seul
but dans la vie et non il n'est pas en
alsace on a appris au lacet genre un
village d'harry potter et j'avoue c'est
assez assez culte on dirait vraiment la
cathédrale de rouen en mieux bon tu vois
moi j'aime bien tous les animaux mais je
me vois mal à offrir à quelqu'un ça
comme paul huchon
tiens je t'aime j'ai soit de paul petite
randonnée 5e kilomètre c'est
complètement faux je partis à 30
secondes
on est clairement un match de basket
alors ici aux etats unis
tous les gens ont les visages de ken et
barbie pas de kent dans leur vie mais
moi je suis parti on est très jaloux
[ __ ] moi j'ai vraiment le visage de
moi j'aime les moments le visage d'un
des morts c'est incroyable c'est parce
qu'on savait mais dans les villes
américaines
ils ont la fâcheuse habitude de mettre
la clim à mort dans les magasins et je
suis en manteau à l'intérieur le mec
acheter son pull tellement il a froissé
rigole pas que toi moi je te parle pas
de toi
j'écoute ce qu'il fait là je fais le
magasin et les seuls produits que j'ai
acheté c'est ça le dentifrice et une
brosse à dents les gens ont dû dire
[ __ ] ce mec devait plus de la gueule
il avait besoin de résoudre ce problème
eux-mêmes
dans les villes comme dans le bus
magique un tableau ses activités avec
des vrais poissons
c'est bien mais on a la chance d'être
invité au spectacle du cirque du soleil
à miami je suis avec thomas du cirque du
soleil et charlotte s'y présentent
c'est mon gars le mcdo state plus
clairement customiser tombeur hier au
choix mon pote
la tradition ici c'est le carnaval qui a
lieu en février à décoller sur toi et
tous les mets aux gens que tu aimes bien
là où la coutume bas mais qu'est ce
qu'il fait lui certaines filles pour
avoir quelques colliers font le choix de
montrer leurs seins et leurs poitrines
donc si certaines d'entre vous veulent
des colliers elle n'hésitez pas à
m'envoyer maintenant maintenant non non
non n'oublieront un beignet à la coke
vas-y hugo croit [ __ ] les portes
dernier moment de kif aux états unis
avant de rentrer en france dans ma terre
natale avec vous voici le décor final
les gars c'est parti pour un générique
[Musique]
et
mais
g
[Musique]